on the way it is well happy wednesday
everybody
beautiful skies out there there are some
high clouds around but there's also a
lot of sunshine we had more clouds
overnight
those actually kind of moved out to the
north and have left us with a really
sunny start to the day there are some
neighborhoods seven hills sunrise
mountain nellis that have dropped into
the 30s prompt you're in the mid 30s
right now it's chilly there mesquite
kingman also in the 30s red rock below
40 degrees
so we're working on really dry
conditions these high clouds will not
bring us rain
we'll look for more to come in through
the day and into thursday
and then breezy north winds setting up
on friday
with a cold front coming in from the
north all these high clouds are coming
up from the south and while they thinned
out now
the low pressure off the coast of baja
will send us more
over the next 36 to 48 hours but the
cold front
is what's really going to change the
temperatures for us so we'll go from
very mild mid to upper 60s today and
tomorrow
hanukkah begins tomorrow at sunset
breezy winds on friday but look how the
temperatures drop we're all the way back
to the 50s which is really normal
for the weekend and mornings down into
the mid 30s gonna be a chilly weekend
geminid meteor shower peak sunday night
if you want to get out in the cold
hours of the overnight hours to see the
beautiful meteor shower show
should be a good one this year